[Captioned via Y Translator]
Halloween's coming up,
and if you're thinking
of being Captain America,
then we've got something
to show you that will make
your shield even more useful
than it usually is.
[Music]
>> Hey guys, I'm here
with my friend Calli.
>> I've helped Nate before
in the past with building
some giant Koopa shells
for the Devin Supertramp videos,
if you've seen those.
You guys also saw
a smaller version
of that on this channel.
>> Fiberglass is
something that
I really prefer to have
an extra set of hands for,
and she has hands.
So this is gonna work
out pretty well.
The basic idea is
that carrying a shield
and a trick-or-treat
bag will use up all
of your hands,
so we found a way
to combine the two,
letting you open the front
of your shield to collect your goodies.
So, to start off,
we've got a little
plastic Captain America shield
that we bought from Amazon.
>> It has some elastic straps
here and there.
They're okay.
>> Well, we've got
some modifications to do,
and the first step is gonna be
a little bit of reinforcement,
and that's what we've got
our fiberglass for.
>> And here we've got
our fiberglass resin
and our fiberglass cloth.
>> So we're going to be using
these two things,
and making a reinforced section
and a circle around here.
>> So the first thing
we're gonna do is
take off these elastic straps,
but we're gonna save them for later.
>> Now, we need to do fiberglass,
and fiberglass is a terrible
thing to do indoors.
It smells really strong.
It has powerful fumes,
you really don't want
to be breathing in.
So we're gonna go
outside for this part.
So now, we've got our shield,
and we're here outside where
there's enough ventilation
that we're not going
to get overwhelmed
with fiberglass fumes,
and we've just got it set up
on this plastic container
to hold it up.
>> To make sure that the fiberglass
bonds really well,
we're gonna go ahead and
sand some parts down here.
So it has something to grips,
and doesn't feel up later.
So while I handle the sanding here,
Nate's gonna cut up that fiberglass mat.
[Music]
>> Okay, here's
our fiberglass resin.
We're gonna be the pouring it
into this bowl.
Here's a tip,
if you ever have a can
or a bottle something
like this where
the spout is on one side,
don't pour it that direction
because it'll usually
block off the air,
and it'll do that
like blub-blub thing.
Pour it from the
other direction.
You usually get
a much smoother pour.
Look at that smooth pour.
Beautiful.
[Music]
So we start off
by brushing on a thin layer
of fiberglass resin, we
then take our fiberglass cloth,
we press it down onto that,
and then we add more
of the resin on top of it.
>> So this ridge that Nate's
pointing to right here,
this is what we want
to go ahead and reinforce
because we're going
to be cutting into that
in just a little bit.
[Music]
This is gonna take a little bit
of time to cure.
Actual cure time depends
on how much catalyst we added,
and the temperature outside,
so we'll just come check on it
about every 20 minutes,
and see how it's doing.
In the meantime,
we've got stuff
to build back inside,
where it's not quite so cold.
Now, while the fiberglass is curing,
as I said, we're gonna start
building the internal
and moving parts of this.
So, we have here a caulking gun
and a piece of wood.
From this, we need to cut
two pieces that are
approximately the length
of the second circle
on the inside of our shield.
So we're gonna have
Calli measure
and cut those,
while I start
modifying our caulking gun.
>> The last thing you want
is resin in your hair.
Pretty much most
of these supplies,
you don't want in your hair.
Right now, we're just
measuring the piece
of wood to fit the inside
of this inner second circle.
>> Now, we're gonna have this piece
of aluminum working as a sort
of hinge that swells
and pushes out the front part
of our shield.
So Calli's going to shape this.
We've got a curved end
on one side,
a couple of spots to drill,
and we'll cut it off,
and that will be part
of our opening mechanism.
[Music]
Easy enough,
and then we need our grip.
She'll be a little harder to cut.
[Music]
That should work.
Caulking guns are cheap,
and they have a prebuilt
handle with a hinge,
with a spring in it,
which is just what
we're looking for right now.
So we're gonna take
this caulking gun,
and we're gonna start kind
of cutting it to pieces.
We just want the handle part.
[Music]
All right, now we've got
several pieces cut out,
so we can begin to show you
how this mechanism is going
to be working.
Our handle is going
to get mounted,
and we're gonna bend
this metal strap into place.
So that, that will be attached
onto these bars,
then we'll have a piece
of metal that goes
from the black handle around,
and that will go over
to this piece, which
will be mounted on a hinge.
So when we pull this handle,
that will push on the back,
causing this to swing out,
and that's what's going
to push open our shield.
So now, we need
to mount this handle
onto these two pieces of wood.
Like I said,
we've got this metal strap,
and this is what
we're going to be using.
So, let's start bending this,
and then cutting it
into the right shape.
We want to lift it up,
so that we have space to fit
our hand underneath the handle,
so we can close it as we like.
Calli just finished
sanding this off,
so I'm less likely
to tear my hand open
while handling it.
I took this metal strap,
and I bent it
in a few places that
should allow us to mount it
both to the wooden sticks
and to our caulking gun handle.
So this will fit right
here on the bottom.
So I bent it to my hand,
but I was also
trying to keep in mind
the placement of the holes,
so I can use those
to mount them on
to both the wooden sticks
and the handle here.
I'm just trying
to line up the holes
in our metal bracket.
With where we want to make
holes, in our handle.
[Music]
>> So you can see here
on the handle,
if we had left it open,
when I was drilling,
we would have actually gotten
this black part drilled too.
And we did not want that.
So we closed it for that part,
goes all the way through,
and then the bottom part
didn't really matter,
so we kept that open.
>> Now we need similarly
drilled holes
into the two sticks,
and that's how we're going
to mount the bracket to that.
[Music]
Now, our handle is mounted
to two sticks,
which is everything
I've ever wanted in the world.
I think at this point,
the fiberglass
on our shield is probably cured,
so we can start
lining things up,
and getting ready
to do more assembly
on the shield itself.
>> Our fiberglass is
pretty much cured,
so slightly more like vibranium,
just if vibranium was slightly
harder plastic?
Yeah.
>> So now, we've got our whole
handle assembly on our shield,
and we can see even better
how things are gonna work.
This piece of aluminum
will go right here.
We'll have this piece of bolt
acting as a sort of hinge,
and then when a piece of metal
extending from the handle over
to this hole pushes on it,
it will spin
and it will push out
the front portion of our shield.
However, before we do that,
we need to make it
so the two pieces are separate.
Right now, we have
the whole shield as one piece,
and we need to pull them apart.
So what we're gonna do
is drill a couple
of holes into the front,
just big enough that we
can fit a jigsaw blade in,
and we're gonna jigsaw
all the way around,
cutting out this blue circle
with the star in it.
We've now got the two
pieces separated,
and while Calli sands those down
so they aren't super scratchy
[inaudible], I'm going to be
doing some measurements,
and attaching some more hardware
onto our hand mechanism.
[Music]
Calli has become
the Captain America shield.
[Music]
Well, at this point, the wrong
thing is moving of course.
But conceptually,
I think we've got something good going on.
Pulling on that handle
is going to push it,
and it's going to force it open.
We've separated the two pieces
of our shield, and now, we
need to put them back together.
Just not quite the same way.
What we want to do is have
this piece on a hinge,
so it opens up.
[Music]
Earlier, we took off these elastic straps
that were the original handles on this shield,
but they weren't quite the right style
for what we were going for, of course.
So now, we're going
to use those pieces
of elastic to work
as a closing mechanism
for our shield.
[Music]
We glued those on fairly tight,
not necessarily pulled tight,
but just nice and flat so
that any opening causes
the elastic to stretch,
so they should spring back nicely.
[Music]
>> So now that we've got
most everything in place,
we want to make sure
it's pretty secure
and pretty permanent.
So we're gonna
be fiberglassing
our wood pieces,
just making sure
that nothing goes anywhere.
Oh no.
I have resin on me.
Your life is over.
I'll be prepared
to have it on me forever.
[Music]
>> Alright, I think we've now had
our fiberglass cure pretty nicely.
So these are gonna hold on,
so I'm no longer worried
about the shield breaking apart
while it's being carried around.
So just a few last touches.
I've actually gone ahead
while that was curing.
I did a little bit of it.
So this is just a pouch
that I threw together
with some scrap pieces
of cloth, and some...
You can see it's got
velcro dots all over it,
and the purpose of this is we
can just attach it like that.
And like that.
So now, when the front
of the shield is open,
it just leads right
down into that bag.
So the whole point of this is
like a trick-or-treating shield.
You open it up like that,
drop candy down in,
and it will just land right
in your trick-or-treat bag.
And if that gets too full,
you can just peel it off,
and make your dad carry all
of your candy in a larger bag,
while you just keep carrying
around the shield.
One more thing we want to do,
and that is to add an arm strap.
So we're gonna use
a staple gun to hold this down.
We're gonna use several staples,
just attaching our leather on
to our piece of wood.
This is a really
simple plastic buckle
from the craft store.
On one side,
it's permanently attached.
On the other side,
it goes to the loop,
so you can tighten it,
but it doesn't really pull back.
Are you gonna attack me while
I'm using this as a shield?
>> Yes.
Wait, no no no.
Yeah, where's the candy?
I'm gonna shot candy at you.
Okay, wait.
Ready?
[Music]
Did you catch any of those?
>> No!
It's vibranium.
Things bounce off of it.
Or nothing bounces off of it?
>> Almost.
Almost.
Keep trying again.
[Music]
This is really fun.
>> Trick or Treat.
[Music]
>> Yeah.
>> Wait.
Guys, thanks for watching.
That's not all.
We've always got more
for you see.
That box up at the top
will take you directly to our last video,
and you should go check that out.
The other box will show
you what YouTube thinks
you should be watching next,
and if you're not subscribe
to the channel yet,
hit this bomb to get
in the club, and that way,
you'll never miss out
on the fun.
Don't forget to ring that bell,
and we will see you in the next one.
Talk to you then.